So as you might
know by now, you can
use Google Cloud Messaging
to send notifications
to iOS devices through APNs.
Now in a previous video,
we shed a little light
on how the APNs half
of this combo works.
Let's see if we can do
the same thing for GCM
on this episode of "Route 85."
[MUSIC PLAYING]
So before we go any
further, I'd recommend
watching this video
on understanding APNs
if you haven't yet.
If you have, here's
a real quick review.
When you send a
notification through APNs,
it requires two important
pieces of information.
First is the device
token, which is basically
an alias for the device
you want to talk to.
Remember, that's like
the secret fake name
rock stars leave at
the hotel register
so that their real
friends can find them.
Second is the APNs
certificate, which basically
contains a public
key that you can
use to communicate with APNs.
Oh yeah, and there's
the notification itself.
So I guess that's three
pieces of information.
Now, sending
notifications through GCM
is similar, but
not quite the same.
Let's look at the two
pieces of information
you need to send a
notification through GCM.
First is the registration token.
Like the APNs device
token, it's the address
of the device you
want to talk to.
Or I guess more accurately,
it's the fake rock star alias
for the device you
want to talk to.
Now, GCM has its own
token that it uses,
but it turns out there are
other services-- not just
Cloud Messaging-- that
could theoretically
use this token, as well.
So while you'll often
hear it referred to
as a GCM registration
token, its real name
is an instance ID token.
And when it gets
down to implementing
this thing for
reals, you're going
to see that you'll be using a
library called the Instance ID
Library to get one of these.
Now second is the API key.
You don't need a certificate
with its own private/public key
combination to communicate
with GCM servers
the way you do with APNs.
Instead, you send
across an API key
that is unique to your
application with every request
that you make.
This API key is generated by
the console when you first
set up your project,
and is what GCM
uses to confirm that, yes,
you really are communicating
on behalf of your application,
which means this is something
you want to treat with the
same kind of sensitivity
as, say, a password.
Don't make it easy for
people to discover.
Don't put it in a public
file on a server somewhere.
And for crying out loud, don't
ever put this on your client.
So if we were using GCM to make
a request to an Android device,
it would look pretty
similar to the APNs flow.
Our server would talk to GCM
using the API key as proof
that, yes, we're really
who we say we are.
Then, we'd use the
registration token
to both find the right device to
talk to, as well as prove that,
yes, we really have the
right to talk to this user
because they gave us
their rock star alias.
Add on the rest of our data,
and our notification gets sent.
Yay.
But we're dealing with
the iOS world, where
things are slightly different.
GCM still needs to route
all of its requests
through APNs if we want to bring
up any kind of notification
in the background or anything.
So before you ask GCM to create
a registration token for you
on iOS, you first need
an APNs device token.
Then, you tell Google
servers, hey, here's
an APNs device token.
Can you create a
GCM registration
token associated with this APNs
token, and then send me a copy.
This is probably
inaccurate, but I
like to think that, when you're
done, there's a database table
out there somewhere that now
has your GCM registration
token, your APNs device
token, and your sender ID
all in a row.
Now, also remember that
GCM, like any other server,
needs an APNs certificate
to communicate with the APNs
service.
Yes, I know that's
still redundant.
Shut up.
So at around the same time
you register your application
with GCM and you
create your API key,
you're also going to upload
your APNs certificate to Google
servers to tell it that this
is the APNs certificate that it
should associate
with its GCM key.
Again, probably
inaccurate, but I
like to think that, in
another database table
somewhere, there's a row that's
got your GCM API key, your APNs
certificate, and your app
sender ID all in a row.
With me so far?
OK, cool.
So let's review the
higher end-to-end process
of sending a notification to
APNs through GCM, starting
with the set-up process.
And yes, I did spend Google's
money purchasing a stock photo
image of an enchilada.
So let's take a moment
to admire it, shall we?
Mm.
All right.
I'm getting hungry.
So at some point when you're
first building your app,
you register with the APNs
servers using iTunes Connect.
You tell it about your
app, your bundle ID,
and you generate your
APNs certificate.
Then, you go ahead and
register that same app
with GCM using the console.
Now at this point,
you're going to get back
an API key, which you'll use to
identify your app to GCM when
you talk with it.
Now at some point, quite
possibly the same time
you're creating this API
key in the first place,
you're also going to upload
your APNs certificate
to GCM servers.
GCM then associates
that certificate
with the app that is
identified by that API key
that it just gave you.
So now let's move on to
the worlds of the client,
and what happens when it asks
to receive some notifications.
First off, your client
will tell iOS, hey,
I want to receive notifications.
iOS will ask the
user if that's OK.
Now, if the user says yes,
iOS registers your app
with its servers and
gets back an APNs device
token-- remember, that's
the fake rock star
alias-- that it
shares with your app.
Your app then needs to ping
the instance ID service which,
for simplicity and because
I'm running out of room here,
we'll pretend is a part of GCM
for its registration token.
And as part of the request, it
passes along the device token
that it just got from APNs.
The instance ID service then
returns a registration token,
and that is the
token you're going
to use if you want to send a
message to this target device.
OK, so registration is done.
Let's see what
happens when we now
want to go ahead and
send a notification.
Now in our scenario,
let's assume
you want to ping this
individual device
and you have a little bit of
code on your server to do it.
For that to work,
the user's client
will now need to send back
this registration token
to your server.
How you do that is
kind of up to you.
So when you want to send a
notification to this device,
your servers are going to send
off a notification request
to the GCM servers.
Now it's going to pass along
the API key and the GCM
token for this device along
with that notification.
GCM servers are going
to verify that the API
key and the registration token
both exist on its servers,
and it's going to make sure
that they both correctly map
to the same app.
Assuming all that's good,
it will then notice, hey,
this registration token contains
an entry for an APNs device
token.
That's its cue that our
target device is actually
an iOS device.
So it'll grab that, along
with the APNs certificate
associated with the
API key, and use
those two bits to
communicate to Apple servers.
It will then take your
notification request,
alter it a bit to fit
Apple's notification format,
and then send that
notification request
to APNs along with the device
token that it found earlier.
Apple will receive
this information,
confirm that everything
looks correct on this end,
and then send the notification
along to the user's device.
Hooray.
All right, well that
was an awful lot of work
just to send one little
notification, right?
But don't worry too
much-- a lot of this work
is setup stuff that
you're only going
to need to do once per app, and
a lot of the other work really
just gets taken care
of automatically
for you behind the scenes.
Now granted, I
haven't talked yet
about things like
upstream messaging--
which is a whole other
kettle of fish-- or topic
messaging or some
other edge cases,
but I think, for the
purposes of getting
started with GCM on iOS, this
is probably everything you need.
See?
Our giant black rectangle is
now a lightish gray rectangle.
So with this information
under your belt,
I suggest you now go and
tackle the documentation,
if you haven't yet.
It'll probably be a little
easier to digest now
that you have some
background information.
And be on the lookout for
future episodes of "Route 85."
I'll see if I can
tackle some of the nuts
and bolts of this process
in a screencast or two.
Wouldn't that be nice?
Yes, it would.
But you're going to have to
wait until after I-- I'm busy.
[MUSIC PLAYING]